okay let's go back to our second top
story so far here on the newshour the
morning the day after the night before
we're talking about the trump
biden debate of course let's speak now
to jack kingston in new york he's a
surrogate for president trump
and formerly a u.s congressman from the
state of georgia
jack welcome back good to talk to you
again the fbi director
a couple of weeks ago a couple of months
ago said white supremacists
in the united states are the number one
terror threat
to the united states given that
why didn't mr trump reject and repudiate
everything that white supremacists stand
for
well i actually think he did reject them
and has announced them
previous to last night we did not hear
joe biden denouncing antifa in fact he
said
antifa is an idea not even an
organization and of course law
enforcement group after group has said
antifa is a huge problem and it is a
real group
it is an organized group and uh joe
biden
almost embraced them i i was shocked at
it um i
i think peter that if it was you or me
we probably would have made our
positions
clearer than either candidate did but um
i know the president
uh trump actually said well what is it
that you want me to say
about the white supremacist group
because i know that he has announced
some and he's not
right jack just just to pause you there
jack i watched the entire debate
on replay because of the time difference
between where i am and where you are
if mr trump denounced the proud boys
white supremacists why have they
literally
taken stand back stand by
and they have incorporated it into their
online
emblem and they are talking about it
because standby
is not the same thing as stand down
stand down means go away
stand by means get ready
you know i think all these terrorist
groups need to be dealt with
and dealt with severely and the law
should be blind when it comes to dealing
with them
um but and i'm not defending this group
at all
but but you don't see them doing the
type of things that we're seeing in
seattle
and portland and chicago and new york
city
which some of these other left-wing
groups are doing which have
caused the death of many people they've
taken over towns they've destroyed
property
these are left-wing groups that are
causing the major decisions
when have these left-wing groups caused
the deaths of many people across america
name me cities give me data did
two deaths in in seattle two two deaths
and then um a police officer i believe
in
louisville but there there have been a
number of deaths associated with
left-wing protests so
there's no gray area to that whatsoever
but listen i want to go hand in hand if
groups want to
get rid of these hard left hard right
extremist groups that are destroying
property and hurting people
i think that's one thing we all should
be able to unite about okay but
but the starting point for this kind of
debate that mr trump
came out fighting with because he came
out he clearly came out in his mind
not to have a presidential debate he
came out to have
a boxing match and simultaneously to the
debate happening
we had his son i watched it on i think
it was msnbc
donald jr talked about on live national
tv
about the charlottesville hoax what was
the charlotteville hoax there was no
hoax
a woman was killed because somebody hit
her with a car that's not a hoax
it absolutely is not a hoax and i'm in
agreement with you what the hoax was
and chris wallace repeated this line
which has been
proven time and time again is not the
case the president said
people who are debating taking down
confederate statues
that there are good people on both sides
he never referred to the white
supremacists
and the other protesters as good people
on both sides
that that is a it's been a left-wing lie
that has been perpetuated by the press
who can't stand trump but if you go back
and listen to
what he said and i actually was working
for cnn
not just that that time but that very
day and i heard him say it live
that there were good people on both
sides of the debate regarding statues
um and and i don't know i don't know why
the left
can't just stay in substance rather than
come up with
accusations like this but you know what
where where i think that there is a
plenty of room for discussion
were some of the issues that we did not
get into like the handling
of covet or health care or the supreme
court there were so many
i think lost opportunities that the
debate got out of chris wallace's
control
okay and um you know they should almost
have a mute button
for both candidates sometimes that might
be a really good idea
can we just talk for a minute or so
about the the tone
and the feeling of the debate you know i
mean you and i had a conversation on
this program
four days ago you're clearly a
conviction politician in a parallel
pocket universe you and i live
next door to each other we could have a
robust conversation about
about politics about donald trump over
the garden wall having a barbecue
whatever i would respect your take on
donald trump you would respect mine we
could move on it would be done within
an inculcated atmosphere of respect for
the other
last night donald trump when i started
listening to him i have to say this
talking as a journalist who's followed
this the past five years of the trump
administration
it was like he was one of his tweets
given human form it was 200 characters
of
shouting of aggression of just talking
down
a man who's had 47 years at the highest
rank of american politics and there was
zero respect
for mr biden did political debate in
america
die last night just a little bit
i i don't think it died but i think
we've been evolving to get to this point
that there it
it's a bare-knuckles um situation now i
think what we
on the right have always been concerned
about is if we sit back politely
then the moderator tends to go over to
the left side and
all the pointed questions are towards
the republicans so
i think that's why the president came
out swinging
i agree with you it was like two old
rivals at a
high school dance that wanted to go out
in the parking lot and settle their
differences
but but i think the president actually
you know intentionally did that but
remember
joe biden on national tv international
tv called the president of the united
states a clown
who does that help joe biden actually
probably had some
opportunities to take the high road but
instead he called the president a racist
a liar
which is also that twitter kind of
language that he might be able to say
what do you say understood sir what do
you say to that debate
that's now happening all over the world
all the hashtags you know
critics of the republican party and
critics of you
might say of donald trump is he the best
you've got really big question mark
because if you go back
five years you know starting with
i'm going to be in delicate yeah grab
them by the blank
fast forward to losers and suckers
go back to oh i've got a big summit in
singapore with the north korean leader
out of which
he got nothing yes fast forward again to
zero tax in 10 of the last 15 years
is he really the best man to be the next
president of the united states
given what he's done over the past five
years when he was candidate trump
and president trump i i would say
that there is plenty of room to
criticize
president trump what we had with romney
what we had with mccain were apologetic
conservatives who would not stand up to
their philosophy
donald trump has done more for the
pro-life movement than any other
president
he's done more for the world he's
talking about let's get
american troops home from some of these
endless wars that both democrat and
republicans
predecessors have gotten us involved in
he had the strongest most robust economy
not just in america but really in the
world
with historically low unemployment rates
for african americans
and hispanics high higher wages that
have
increased um i think he's been tough at
the trade table i would like him to even
be
tougher frankly i think the america
first doctrine is good but
it does not mean america alone it means
um
we're going to look after our interests
you need to look after your interests
but let's do what's best for the world
he has not fallen into any wars he had
the opportunity
and many advisers in both parties were
saying bomb syria let's get involved in
this in a major way
obama did not do enough but the
president has been very controlled about
that
okay and you know as respect it is a
growing global um
entity and if people are more
comfortable with china then they need to
sit back quietly but if there are people
who say you know china could be a
growing threat
they're building up their military
they're building a third aircraft
carrier
um they did not share information openly
as respects the
coronavirus i think the president
sounded great
jack kingston i apologize for
interrupting you uh for a 27th time
during our conversation it was good to
talk to you four days ago it's good to
talk to you now thank you so much for
coming on and joining us here on the
news
jack kingston there talking to us from
georgia many thanks thanks